[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're once again going to
be discussing wizarding wealth it's a
hot topic people want to talk about it
why is harry so rich why do the
lestranges have a vault full of gold who
is the richest family these are all
questions i've answered in the past
however what i've never properly
answered is how the malfoy family were
able to amass their wealth the wizarding
world has an economy just like our own
with mediums of exchange and a system of
finance and they also of course have
their own wizarding money coming in many
different forms including galleons
sickles and canuts galleons are the
largest form of currency equivalent to
about 17 sickles or 493 canuts according
to the forbes fictional 15 which takes
speculation to the next level when it
ranks the net worth of all different
sorts of fictional characters lucius
malfoy is worth an astonishing 1.3
billion usd
or 943 million 542 000 pounds if we
convert that into muggle currency that
gives us a figure of approximately 188
million 708 thousand galleons not bad
lucius astonishingly the malfoys are not
the richest family in the wizarding
world but they're certainly up there
probably top three when we think of the
malfoy family lineage certain words come
to most people's minds but these words
scarcely hold a positive connotation
usually when someone says malfoy you
might think bigot or prejudiced but
that's a reputation that was earned
through centuries of intolerance in fact
the name malfoy comes from old french
and literally means bad faith these are
characteristics almost ingrained in
their bloodline and it wasn't until
really draco that this intolerance began
to weigh the somewhat historically they
are a wealthy family of morally crooked
witches and wizards that will whimper
when caught red-handed and gloat when in
a position of power so how did this
family acquire their immense level of
wealth well i'm about to air their dirty
dark secret they're rich exclusively
because of muggles
per pottermore like many other
progenitors of noble english families
the wizard armand malfoy arrived in
britain with william the conqueror as
part of the invading norman army having
rendered unknown shady and almost
certainly magical services to king
william the first malfoy was given a
prime piece of land in wiltshire seized
from local landowners upon which his
descendants have lived for 10
consecutive centuries their wily
ancestor armand encapsulated many of the
qualities that have distinguished the
malfoy family to the present day the
malfoys have always had the reputation
hinted at by their not altogether
complementary surname of being a
slippery bunch to be found courting
power and riches wherever they might be
found in spite of their spousal of
pureblood values and their undoubtedly
genuine belief in wizard superiority
over muggles the malfoys have never been
above ingratiating themselves with the
non-magical community when it suits them
the result is that they are one of the
richest wizarding families in britain
and it has been rumored for many years
though never proven that over the
centuries the family has dabbled
successfully in muggle currency and
assets over hundreds of years they have
managed to add to their lands in
wiltshire by annexing those of
neighbouring mughals and the favor they
carried with royalty added muggle
treasures and works of art to an ever
expanding collection
isn't it horribly ironic that the
malfoy's wealth of which they are so
proud stems from the very thing that
they vowed to hate so much but the
reality is this hypocrisy has been going
on for a very long time in fact one of
the malfoy's ancestors who was arguably
the most anti-muggle malfoy was a wizard
named brutus malfoy who once remarked
that nothing is a sure sign of weak
magic than a weakness for non-magical
company well what does that say about
your bloodline then mr brutus in fact as
it turns out brutus malfoy the man who
sat on a pile of muggle provided money
was the editor of the anti-muggle
periodical warlock at war he assumed
this position because he didn't want to
just sit idly by hating muggles he
wanted to spread the word and he wanted
to demonize anyone that would fraternize
with muggles or muggle borns he even
believed that witches and wizards who
associated with muggles was stupid and
lacked magical talent an entirely skewed
perspective likely fabricated out of
hate in 1675 he said the following this
we may state with certainty
any wizard who shows fondness for the
society of muggles is of low
intelligence with magic so feeble and
pitiful that he can only feel himself
superior if surrounded by muggle pigmen
nothing is a sure sign of weak magic
than a weakness for non-magical company
however with all of that said the
malfoys have always drawn one line in
the sand when it comes to fracturing
with muggles and that line of course
pertains to their level of wealth yes
armand malfoy who served william the
conqueror was given land in exchange for
services but that's not the only source
of their wealth the malfoys also massed
paintings gold jewels and all other
kinds of valuable goods all through
fraternizing with wealthy muggles
historically the malfoys drew a sharp
distinction between poor muggles and
those with wealth and authority until
the imposition of the statute of secrecy
in 1692 the malfoy family was active
within a high-born muggle circles and it
is said that their fervent opposition to
the imposition of the statute was due in
part to the fact that they would have to
withdraw from this enjoyable sphere of
social life
though hotly denied by subsequent
generations there is ample evidence to
suggest that the first lucius malfoy was
an unsuccessful aspirant to the hand of
elizabeth the first and some wizarding
historians allege that the queen's
subsequent opposition to marriage was
due to a jinx placed upon her by the
thwarted malfoy yeah you heard that
right the malfoys were in opposition to
the statute of secrecy because it
threatened their lifestyle however this
fact certainly didn't mean that they
wouldn't later pivot on their position
entirely later vocalizing a fervent
stance supporting the divide of the two
worlds with that healthy degree of
self-preservation that has characterized
most of their actions over the centuries
once the statute of secrecy had passed
into law the malfoys ceased fraternizing
with muggles however well-born and
accepted that further opposition and
protests could only distance them from
the new heart of power the newly created
ministry of magic they performed an
abrupt vault face and became as vocally
supportive of the statute as any of
those who had championed it from the
beginning hastening to deny that they
had ever been on speaking or marrying
terms with muggles in typical malfoy
fashion the family tucked their tails
between their legs and upon recognizing
that the statute was going to be
introduced whether they liked it or not
quite openly changed their perspective
on the whole thing this type of behavior
is consistent with the malfoy's and
reminds me of i don't know lucius who
was a devout death eater when voldemort
was standing next to him but would
switch sides in a heartbeat if he
recognized the chance of voldemort's
downfall over time without the supply of
jewels and goods that previously came
from muggles the contempt toward them
eventually became genuine and there you
have it the massively hypocritical truth
regarding the malfoy's and the reason
for their immense wealth i'm sure if you
asked lucius or draco about how the
family amassed their fortune they'd give
you a very different answer but this
this is the truth and that's it for this
video if you enjoyed the content please
like the video subscribe to the channel
and leave a comment down below until
next time it does not do to dwell on
dreams forget to live
[Music]
you